good morning and welcome to today's
presentation titled smart glass how
metal ions might revolutionize tinting
and energy efficiency my name is Joe
Garcia and I am the program manager for
the energy innovation and emerging
technologies program today's featured
presenter is Mike McGee Mike McGee is a
professor in a material science and
engineering department and a senior
fellow of the Precourt Institute for
energy his research interests are
developing new materials for smart
windows and solar cells he has taught
courses on nanotechnology nano
characterization organic semiconductors
polymer science and solar cells
he received his undergraduate degree in
physics from Princeton University and
his PhD in material science from the
University of California at Santa
Barbara where he did research on polymer
lasers in a lab of Nobel laureate Allen
Hager
now I'd like to turn the floor over to
Mike thank you for participating in this
webinar
yeah today I'm going to tell you about
an exciting dynamic window technology
that the students and postdocs in my lab
have developed and on this very first
slide you can go ahead and see it on the
left the window is in its clear state
and then in the next picture to the
right you can see it partially tinting
and you can see a nice neutral gray
color and then if you go over one more
you can see it in a nice black opaque
steak and then if you go all the way to
the right you see that the window has
switched back to the transparent state
so let me step back and and motivate why
we would want to have these windows when
I look forward into the future
it's hard for me to believe that we're
going to have self-driving cars and yet
still be controlling glare by rotating
you know metal slats like you can see
with the window blinds on the left and
that picture illustrates how
time's the blinds can get all hung up
and not work very well on the right you
you see an example where half of the
window is letting too much light in and
there's a lot of glare and then on the
other half
there is tinting and it illustrates that
that really the best way to control
glare is not to completely block the
light with blinds or curtains but rather
to just attenuate it more like when
you're wearing sunglasses that way you
can still enjoy the view and we're not
just developing dynamic windows because
it'll create a more pleasing environment
in inside all kinds of buildings and
cars and airplanes it's also about
saving energy and this slide has some
data that was collected by view dynamic
glass and they show that the the energy
savings you can have with cooling and
heating and lighting if you have dynamic
windows and they're intelligently
controlled such that they're they're
letting in light under certain
conditions so that people can use the
natural light and use less artificial
lighting and in the winter the light is
coming in to heat the building but
during other conditions in the summer
when when that unwanted heat is
resulting in the need for air
conditioning then the windows can can
block it and you know this studies show
that approximately 20 percent of the
heating and cooling and ventilation and
lighting costs can be saved
if dynamic windows are properly used and
then in this next slide you can see
something from the from view glasses
website and their window is switching
between clear and dark and
I won't show their video right now but
there's a web address for it and you can
hear one company explain how their
control system would work and it would
have weather data it would have data
from light sensors on top of the
building it would know the layout of the
building and you know where people's
desks are and it would make good
decisions on what the tinting of the
various windows should be at various
points in the in the day you know I want
to talk about some of the approaches
that people are using to control tinting
a lot of people ask me how the windows
that I'm going to tell you about later
are different from eyeglasses with
dynamic tinting those have photochromic
materials in them and they they darken
when they're exposed to UV light and you
know one thing that's really nice about
them it's all automatic and there's no
need for a power supply however that
some of the downsides
they don't darken in a car because the
the car windows filter all of the UV
light so you still need sunglasses for
driving in a car and if you don't like
the tinting state that arises there's
really nothing you can do about it if
you're outside and you're in a
photograph for example and you don't
want it to the light the eyeglass is to
go dark you can't override it and and
also let's say you're skiing and it's
extremely bright photo comics don't have
a wide range they they can't go down to
say 1% transmission so it'd be good to
have a technology with more control and
a wider range another approach are
suspended
particle devices and and here there are
particles sandwiched between a couple of
electrodes and applying a field can line
the particles up and then light can go
in between the particles when there's no
field the particles take more of a
random distribution and you know block
more of the light and and this is
already being used in the sky roof of
some cars but I've heard various people
say that it's too expensive and others
say that it's it's very hazy so that
brings me to electrochromic s-- which is
probably the leader for window
applications and in an electric Romek
device there are two transparent
electrodes usually made of indium tin
oxide and on at least one of them
there's an electro chromic material such
as tungsten oxide and if the voltage is
applied in one direction then the
tungsten oxide is reduced lithium comes
into it and in in in that state the
material is it's much darker although
it's not gray or black it tends to be
somewhat blue and then on the other
electrode there's some counter material
sometimes it's electrochromic and it
switches color too sometimes it's just a
transparent material that helps allow
the electrochemical reactions to take
place on on both sides tungsten oxide is
typically sputtered and in in these
devices both of the transparent
electrodes the electrochromic the
electrolyte and the counter material
they're all sputtered so there can be a
couple microns of the material and that
means that the you need a long line of
sputter tools or or have a lower
throughput on a smaller system so it is
somewhat expensive
another problem is that sometimes there
are pinholes in other words regions
missing the material and and so those
spots don't switch color and so
typically the yield is only about 1/3
and and that means that 2/3 of the
windows are having to be thrown out and
I think those are the primary reasons
why this technology is at about 50
dollars per square foot and I've heard
from people in the industry that um it's
20 to 30 dollars per square foot is
probably where the technology would be
much more widely adopted than it
currently is there is a lot of
excitement for this technology and I
think there's a lot of sense that
something big is about to happen right
around the corner and companies like
control and view and sage they don't
usually reveal exactly what they're
making but it's probably tungsten oxide
or some similar metal oxide and you can
see control has raised 100 million view
has raised at least 650 million and sage
glass was acquired by Sango bean and
then there are other other smaller
companies as well that are working on
innovative dynamic glass technologies
probably the most commercially
successful electrochromic a company is
Gentex and they use a molecule methyl
viola j'en that switches colors when
it's oxidized and reduced and they chose
an application that's an easier one than
Windows they they make the rearview
mirrors for cars that have a light
sensor and if someone is driving behind
the car and the high beams are in the
the mirror it'll sense that and darken
the window as you can see in the slide
there and so they have about one and a
half billion dollar per year sales for
that product they also make the windows
for the the Boeing 787 Dreamliner and
here you can you can see one of their
photographs and on the left you have a
completely clear window and then it's
getting darker as it goes over to the to
the right I took some of photographs
myself when I was in a Dreamliner
recently and I spend a good chunk of the
flight observing you know how people
were using the windows and and asking
people how they liked it and generally
people they do liked it they they liked
the fact that when the window is
darkened you you can still see what's
outside you don't completely lose the
view the pilot loves it because they can
make all the windows go clear before
landing which is a you know a
requirement but you also see that
because the window switches over a
period of minutes and a lot of people
don't think it's working when they push
the button and so they keep pushing the
button over and over you also see that
it's not currently dark enough for a lot
of people if they're trying to sleep
and it's very bluish in fact in the next
slide you can see my hand when the
window is in the clear state and then my
hand when it's in the dark state and you
can see that it's it's a very blue
window and you can imagine particularly
in homes and restaurants and office
buildings people wouldn't want to have
that blue color and they wouldn't like
the way it makes other people appear so
it's clearly important
to make the windows switch faster to
have them go darker and and then to have
a more neutral color I have read an
article just in the last few weeks that
Gentex is releasing a next-generation of
the window that is supposed to be better
but I haven't seen that and I don't know
what they did to improve that window so
I just to highlight some of the needs
here for Windows technology it needs to
have uniform switching and I should
elaborate that a lot of the technologies
they work well when they're small but
it's hard to make a large window switch
fast and the reason is that when the
window is large its drawing a large
amount of current and that when that
current goes through the transparent
electrode there's a voltage drop just
due to Ohm's law and then you know the
switching depends on the voltage and so
the windows switch faster on the edges
where the voltage is high and and slower
in the in the center and and and that
leads to an effect called iris Singh
so probably better electrodes are needed
or windows that switch with a lower
current and then I've highlighted very
high contrast is needed particularly if
privacy is needed say in a situation
residential situation you have to go
below 0.1% transmission to create a
state where people outside I can't see
in and then of course the windows need
to be durable they should be stable in
the resting state meaning that if you
turn it dark it will stay dark
preferably without having to continue to
apply power and then it's very important
that the windows have very low haze in
other words that they not
late so with all that in mind we we
wanted to take a completely different
approach where we're not completely
convinced that the leading technologies
out there will ever have all of the
properties that are needed for for the
most demanding applications like like
windows in homes and commercial
buildings and we thought of a totally
different way that is to use metal
instead of metal oxides it only takes
about 20 to 30 nanometers of metal to
completely block light you don't need
microns just 20 to 30 nanometers and
also metals are very durable and you
know the challenge in this application
is that and and and and for most of the
situations the materials are exposed to
full sunlight and a wide range of
temperatures metals you know can handle
that without any trouble and then in the
approach I'm about to show you where
we're gonna have a transparent electrode
and then we're gonna have just a metal
grid for the other electrode and then
we're just going to inject an
electrolyte liquid in between and that
can be done quickly and very
inexpensively compared to sputtering a
couple of microns of material so yeah
this next slide just just shows what
we're doing we're gonna we're gonna
plate metal when we want the window to
darken and then we're just going to
strip it when we want it to go clear
we're really just moving metal from a
transparent conducting oxide over to
just a metal grid counter electrode the
postdoc in my group Chris Brule thought
carefully about what metals should be
used
and he created this table and down at
the bottom of the table are some
candidate materials that would be
inexpensive but these materials are hard
to plate and it would be very difficult
to reversibly plate them because they're
very prone to oxidation and once they
oxidize then it's hard to strip them if
we go up to the top things like gold
platinum palladium they're very
resistant to oxidizing however perhaps
for the same reason they're they're very
expensive metals so in between are some
attractive candidates silver copper
bismuth lead and we found that they work
very well and we started with copper
because it's well-known that copper can
be electroplated and and there's a lot
of literature on how to do it but copper
by itself is red so we needed to put
another metal in there to get a neutral
color
we started with lead because there's so
much known about the electrochemistry of
lead since it's used in lead acid
batteries and we made great windows and
but the early feedback we got is that it
was a non-starter to have lead in these
windows so we moved on to silver and and
and and we're also able to make nice
windows with that and and that's what's
reported in our our manuscript in the
journal jewel so I'll tell you a little
bit about how we got this working our
first attempts were on bare indium tin
oxide and we we had some success but it
didn't work as well as we would have
liked here you can see scanning electron
microscope images and you see that there
are
certain you know just particles of the
the metals plating and it's not plating
uniformly everywhere and light is able
to go in between the particles and even
worse than that when we cycled it a
thousand times and looked at the
morphology with SEM we found that the
morphology was changing a lot and we're
reasonably sure that that happens
because we don't think we're able to
completely strip the metal off of the
indium tin oxide and the residual metal
influences the the the future growth and
here you can see when we were doing a
cycling experiment where we would plate
for 60 seconds and then strip for 60
seconds the the the minimum transmission
was getting worse and worse over time
and then Chris decided to that the
problem was that only some sites on the
itor good for plating metal and so he
attached platinum nanoparticles to the
surface knowing that um metal will plate
more easily on platinum than it will on
i.t oh and and that worked really well
we we still we don't have a continuous
thin film of metal we're still getting
nanoparticles of metal but you can see
in these SEM images that there's there's
a pretty good you know distribution all
patches on the window have a fairly
similar morphology and we found that
when we cycled it a thousand times we
didn't get significant changes in the
morphology
we believe that in the stripped cycle
all of the metal
is off and we're then starting over
again with a clean platinum surface and
with that when we cycled it back and
forth
we got consistent results over a
thousand cycles and I'll show even more
cycles you know later on in this
presentation here we're cycling between
90 and 40% transmission we can we could
go deeper we we just we're using a less
aggressive cycling and and just we were
just doing a short switch there to do a
thousand cycles relatively quickly this
next slide shows you know just how low
the transmission can go we see here that
after a few minutes the the transmission
is as well below 1% and a lot of people
ask what the switch time is and you know
that just depends on how dark someone
you know once the window to go and just
say 10 seconds it's already you know
down around 30% which is clearly
darkened but it takes a few minutes to
pleat enough metal to go below 1% and
this slide does illustrate that this
technology has a very wide range because
we can just keep plating metal we can
make the windows go as dark as anyone
wants them to go this next slide shows
the spectrum you you've already seen
pictures so you can see that these
things do look black and and here's just
quantitative data showing how the
spectrum is going down with time it also
shows that this just keeps going into
the infrared and I'm not showing it here
but the the attenuation goes out well
past 2009 I mean
which is as far as as we've measured it
and of course that makes complete sense
this this is metal and you know metal is
it's very effective at blocking light
over an extremely wide spectral range
and then you can see the spectrum just
return to its normal state if we reverse
the voltage on the right you you see two
days worth of data
so first the device is put in its opaque
state and then the power is removed and
you can see the metal stays put and so
with no power consumption the window
stays in its dark state and and then at
the 24 hour mark the metal is stripped
and then again the power is taken away
and it'll stay in its transparent state
so this technology consumes you know
very little power just uses a small
amount of power during the switch and
and that's it here you can see all the
steps we use to make a window we start
with a piece of glass that you can see
in the first box and then we we put a
butyl rubber edge seal around there it's
probably not optimized yet but it's
something we just happen to have in our
lab for packaging solar cells and then
we put copper tape around there and
that's going to be the counter electrode
for a window this size we don't need a
fine grid of copper throughout the
window and then where we're putting on
some more rubber edge seal over that
then we have a second piece of glass
that has the eye tio on it and it has
copper tape around the edges to help
spread the currents so we'll be a
bringing current in from all around the
edge of the device and and step 5 here
we've sandwiched all of that together
and then we're putting it on a hot plate
at 120 degrees C we put some weight on
top of that and that presses the two
pieces of glass together and the rubber
is a little bit softened up and and we
get a nice seal between the two pieces
of glass and then coming over into step
we have the electrolyte solution there's
some polymer there in there hydroxyl oxy
cellulose which is also used in hair gel
and it's got the metal ions in there and
with one syringe and needle we inject
that and then there's another needle to
help remove air from the other side and
that gives us a complete window this
slide takes a more detailed look at some
of the optics you can see the
transmission in clear and the dark state
and in the in the in the clear state it
is clear in the visible but the the eye
tio is absorbing out in the infrared and
then we we see that there's not a whole
lot of reflection off of the device
maybe 10 to 20 percent most of the the
the impact of plating metal is in the
absorption and we see here were you know
we're getting about 80 percent
absorption across most of the film and I
don't think we understand that in full
detail yet but having this nano
structured metal is causing the light to
get very heavily scattered and then
we're probably exciting a lot of plasma
resonances in the nanoparticles that's
leading to a strong absorption but yeah
what's what's there is some debate some
think it would be great to reflect the
light and that would keep the window
cool and and it would just reject the
heat but a lot of people we've talked to
actually prefer the absorption and the
black color and point out that you you
really don't want your your your window
to look like a mirror and then and there
are even laws in Singapore for example
saying that the windows cannot reflect
more than thirty percent because then
you can you can just send light over to
other buildings and also if there's a
little bit of curvature in the window
you can have a light focusing effect and
and and certain spots can get very hot
so for a lot of the applications it's
probably very good that these colors
that these films are absorptive and
black I think it's also worth explaining
that the these films do not obey beers
law I'll admit when we designed the
project that was the plan but the the
transmission does does not drop
exponentially with film thickness and
that is because we don't have metal
everywhere and and so more light gets
through than you would expect from beers
law because light is going you know in
between the particles and there's some I
think good and bad news associated with
that probably the good side of it is
that our transmission versus deposition
time a curve isn't quite as steep as the
beers law curve and that means that we
can have just slight variations in film
thickness and not have a huge you know
very
in transmission but I will say we're
gonna at least try to have the metal
plate everywhere because if it does and
we get to the beers law curve then we
will get low transmissions with less
metal and that will mean with less
current and and that'll mean that we can
switch the window faster and here's data
for a window with a copper silver gel
electrolyte we cycled it 50 500 times
and then at that point decided that um
we needed to use our two potentia stats
for other experiments but it was very
exciting that we didn't see degradation
due to cycling after that many cycles so
just to review some of the highlights
here I think are the key advantage that
we have with reversible metal electrode
deposition compared to electro comics
based on transition metal oxide is the
the gray color in the in the partially
tinting state and the the black color
when it's highly opaque right now I
think our switching speeds are
comparable people who've read our paper
are excited about the fast switch but to
be fair to the competition if we made
meter by meter windows we would have to
run them slower as well to prevent the
IRA Singh however I'm optimistic that we
can improve the metal morphology and and
get to a switch situation where we do
switch 2 to 5 times faster for for a
window of the same size I think it would
be premature for me to put out a number
on on
cost particularly as a professor who's
never run a factory but if I just
compare this directly to the
electrochromic s' I think it's very
promising that it can be cheaper we have
less material that is sputtered in a
vacuum chamber and so I think there's
you know good potential to reduce cost
and then a last advantage is the very
high range of transmission and that we
can go dark enough to have privacy so
when we look forward to our challenges
we're gonna it would be really wonderful
if a large window could switch rapidly
we're heard we've been told that it's
not necessarily a requirement for
architectural applications that
certainly a smart control system knows
what the Sun is going to do and can
start darkening the window before the
glare gets too bad but we hear other
people say and you know especially those
who want to put this in automobile car
roofs that you really want a fast switch
when people press a button they want to
see something happen right away
otherwise they they might think it's
broken
and so if if the improvement here it
might be in having the metal more
effectively block lights so that we can
use less of it but it's probably more in
making a better electrode and we've got
some ideas for incorporating metal grid
lines into the electrodes so that we can
pass more current without a voltage drop
and then of course long-term stability
is going to be crucial and you know we
have to make sure not only that we can
cycle it but it has to handle
ultraviolet light we can't have the
polymer gel breakdown in the UV light we
have to make sure that it can handle an
elevated temperature for a long time we
are seeing some issues with the indium
tin oxide being etched and and we're
moving towards more stable electrodes
for that and finally I'd like to thank a
really outstanding team Chris Barilla
was the postdoc who developed all of the
chemistry for this project and he's now
a professor at the University of
nevada-reno
and dan has you know interacted with a
lot of the companies as part of a class
he took on entrepreneurship and learned
a lot about what the needs are for
dynamic windows and did a lot of the
work in the optics and building the
package and Tyler and Michael and Teresa
are developing some even better
chemistry's that I haven't shown you yet
but you will see some even better
windows down the future and then finally
I really want to thank the Stanford
Precourt Institute for energy for giving
us a seed grant to get this going this
was a completely new area for our group
and it was great
have someone give us this chance to try
something new and I thank you all for
your attention and I hope you enjoyed
this presentation thank you again for
joining us for the presentation today
just a reminder that this presentation
is sponsored by the energy innovation
and emerging technologies program please
visit energy innovation stanford.edu if
you'd like to learn more about this type
of technology as well as some of the
courses we have to offer such as solar
cells which is related to generating
electricity and residential commercial
utility and off-grid sectors
once again please
visit energy innovation stanford.edu
you